the coronavirus is spreading even faster
than it did in the spring
adding to frustration in some areas over
the lack of a coordinated national
response
as our lead national correspondent david
begner reports from miami
some people are taking their own action
to help slow the spread
the spread of covet 19 is reaching
critical new levels
the cdc now predicts there will likely
be up to 30
000 new deaths in the united states over
the next three weeks
we have a perfect storm cbs news medical
contributor dr david agus
believes that delays in testing and the
lack of a national mask mandate
will keep driving numbers up we're going
back to where we were
the sad truth is that if we all wear a
mask
for three to four weeks the numbers
would plummet
that is why sean cannone is taking
matters into his own hands
you don't want someone who is an at-risk
person to be fighting the virus on the
streets
driving through broward county florida
in a converted ambulance
canonies covet 19 outreach includes
temperature checks and handing out masks
and sanitizers to people who are
homeless and may be contributing to the
spread of the virus in the community
not only is it the moral thing to do it
helps stopping the spread
61-year-old robert shackleford a history
teacher
died wednesday from coronavirus after
spending four weeks
at a hospital in sarasota florida his
mother clarine told us he was a huge
green bay packers fan
a father and helped to care for his
autistic brother stephen
i'm devastated
i'm sad i can't believe that that
happened he was such a good son
you know health officials say cases are
surging across the sun belt
alabama set a new record thursday with
nearly twenty four hundred new cases
louisiana topped one hundred thousand
yesterday
we're certainly not where we want to be
in louisiana there are signs of progress
in at least one recent covet hot spot
the state of arizona is now seeing its
numbers of new cases
drop just over three weeks after the
governor closed bars and gyms
again here's the governor doug ducey
there's no
victory lap today there's there's no
celebration
okay we cannot let up
you know florida set a single day record
for the number of deaths yesterday and
so did california the cdc is now saying
that over the next four weeks the states
with the greatest likelihood for a large
number of deaths
are the following i want to read them to
you alabama georgia
idaho nevada oklahoma south carolina
texas utah and right here in florida
tony it's a longer list than we would
like david begnoforce david thank you
very much